(bright music)
- [Narrator] What may seem
like a beautiful oasis,
is actually the top of an active volcano.
(bright music)
Located in Java, Indonesia,
is the Kawah Ijen volcano.
At its top sits a crater lake
filled with hydrochloric acid.
The water is 90 degrees
Fahrenheit and appears
a blueish green.
No species lives in or around the water,
as the conditions are too
harsh for nature to survive.
At night a rare phenomenon can be seen.
Unlike any other volcano
in the world, Kawah Ijen
emits what appears to
be bright blue flames.
This blue glow is not caused by lava,
but instead from a combustion
of sulfuric gasses.
Ones the gasses cool, a
bright yellow sulfur forms,
which is mined and sold.
Miners use steel bars to break
off portions of the sulfur,
and carry up to 200 pounds
back down the volcano.
The emitted gasses are toxic if inhaled,
making this strenuous
work incredibly dangerous.
While this unique volcano maybe home
to one of the world's most grueling jobs,
it is also a sight worth seeing.
(bright music)